[Music]
everybody jog your memories real quick
see if you can finish this okay don't
don't don't kill it though we're going
to go for a couple
okay this old man he played one he
played knickknack on my
thumbn pattack
a this old man running home this old man
don't know
he
play he played knickknack on my
Shick rolling I don't know I don't know
this but you know it but you don't know
but I know the words I know the melody
you probably knew the words at one point
in your life right nope I've never been
good lyrics is it Patty back cuz you
know when you're a kid you remember
weird words knickknack patty whack give
a dog a yeah oh know the cuz like when
you're a kid and you learn the Pledge of
Allegiance you think everyone's saying
invisible yeah invisible invisible
that's yeah I guess so and Liberty is
for all and liberty and justice for all
thank you and I thought the Pledge of
Allegiance was like the Lord's Prayer I
I thought it was just something you do
at church too it kind of was though
right guess so the Church of America
Star Spangled Banner you know um so that
the origins of that song often times
those kind of like child nursery rhymes
Andor stories they have like darker oh
yeah like Ring Around the Rosie pocket
posie what's Ring Around the Rosie ashes
we all that's the black plague yeah
that's about the plague right that's the
black give us more info iing Around The
Rosy pocket full of posy and it's ashes
cuz it's all the burn burn bodies We All
Fall Down fall down cuz everyone dead
damn that's pretty it's kind of tight
huh kids are [__] up back then huh
kids are bummers back then so same thing
like dark humor there's there's a theory
as to like where the knickknack Patty
wack g dog a bone thing came from um
apparently it's thought that the song
dates back well over 150 years um but
this is this again this is a what do you
think nicknack meant back then well
here's the thing SS like a slur nicknack
nicknack Nick snack somebody somebody
theorized and explained that most people
believe it was written around the time
of the Irish Potato Famine from 1842 to
1852 and during that time the country
which was under the control of the
British Empire was blighted by a disease
that infected most of its important crop
leading to a period of starvation that
became known as the Great Famine
everybody ring I remember that remember
Irish people came to America during that
time remember to to England first though
oh that's why it's knickknack patty
whack cuz Patty oh patties are Irish
right with the whack you whack the
patties you
whack whack so that that Great Famine
led to around a million deaths
approximately a quarter of the country's
population so as a result many left
moving to England to find work and a new
life in order to make a living patties
as they were known to the English would
sell knickknacks oh so in order to make
a living four leaf clovers and [__]
keychains whatever might be so according
to Theory when they tried selling their
items door too they would they would go
door too and knock on English stores
knickknack and they'd be given a whack
and sent on their way while their dog
would be given a bone as is the
song A describes the brutal and inhume
treatment of the Irish people who were
persecuted by the British during its
rule so they were like the the Mormons
get off my porch kind of like that they
were like the minorities yeah like get
the hell out of here rad freak you
[__] freak that the interesting idea
that like as a bunch of kids you're just
like [__] happily go lucky singing
these songs but it's talking about like
English people beating Irish people when
they were like dying of starvation and
stuff yeah get the hell out out of here
yeah do we have any like Rodney King
type
songs dude you know what kids should be
say cuz that's the same sentiment right
it's like kids making up songs about Co
now like oh it's like you know that
creative put a mask on take it off
coughing then your grandpa dies oh [__]
but he had core
morbidities I don't think kids can say
that so he didn't need the vaccine at
all brought you by fiser and dinner yeah
you remember uh like cuz pretty good the
old fairy tales right like things like
hanso and gredle we always get like the
children's version but isn't it cuz of
like a pedophile like grabbed them up
and [__] or whatever I mean is that
really what it is it's a lady right even
if it wasn't a pedophile and she still
takes them and puts them in a [__]
oven and eats them and cannibalizes them
you don't use the word cannibal in in
the story but is that
the story of Pinocchio is really dark
too yeah did you hear about the one
about the they said that it's actually
trying to tell you about Epstein Island
yeah I mean that came later but the
actual story like the actual writing
like the author um is a pretty dark
story why is it so dark give me the
spark notes oh the sisters Grim version
is is like the the Grim versions of
everything go ahead because in the
Pinocchio you know in the scene where
he's like and then they go to this
island but they don't come back as boys
they come back as [__] up boys and
they're like but what did they do to him
and then he whispers in his ear and then
the guy's
like like that you don't remember that
scene no yeah it was scary and you're
like no don't send them to the island
that was like the thing did you ever
watch the newer one that one was pretty
good you mean you the Benicio no I mean
the Delo Del Delo I saw the end of itad
because the the dark part was the old
man that lost his real son didn't want
to let go of that son even though he's
already dead so he like got so obsessed
he got super drunk and made a wooden
like doll to represent his son and then
you know the whole the rest of the whole
Pinocchio story where he comes to life
cuz japedo lost his son yeah so that was
the real story lost his real son and
then how did he lose his real son though
uh it was because Nazis eaten by a
[__] old Nazis it was well in that
story I think it was Nazis or or B Bally
fascist or somebody was doing a bombing
and they bombed the church and then the
boy died there a few different
variations of Pinocchio um but you have
to like really go into like a deep cut
of like the original author who wrote
the story um and his is very
depressing and then there's like
variations that follow from that yeah
nothing gets more depressing than war
and like alcoholism and all that
crazy so and and like not wanting to let
go of that fact what about the three
little bears what is that really about I
know that's a happy Story three kids
dying yeah what is the real story you
know like um this idea of us keeping the
childhood and kids like that's a very
New Concept new as in like less than 100
years or like even 50 years because like
uh apparently kids like well for one
they didn't go to school right so
straight if you're poor you just
straight work and then you see all those
old pictures like kids are taking care
of kids oh true and then you see a bunch
of kids like freaking with covered in
mud and stuff cuz they they're in the
coal mines and [__] working at the
factories yeah there was no childhood
back then no childhood you go straight
to work and you start you yeah you could
play with [__] but there's no childhood
like the way that we preserve it yeah
and then um they saw death like you just
saw things die like animals die people
die people die on the street people you
know it's not like all oh we can't we
can't uh let them see that [__] got more
sensitive when you know people started
going oh you know we can't have children
watching this saying these things and
blah blah blah blah why do you think
they did that I feel like cuz they're
kids and we need to protect their sacred
minds and hearts but what led to that is
what I it's probably natural for every
generation to want to give a better life
for their children so like let's say if
you're a coal miner right and you're
just like covered in [__] mud all day
and then you're just like [__] man I
don't want my kids to do that so then
what you try to do is you try to send
your kid to become like educated in
middle class like what all of our
parents did like cuz that was the way
out yeah and then and then every
generation they become more and more
[__] cuz they're like you know I want
my kids to do whatever they want to do
of life is you be you have a trade-off
of like all right you either going to be
more of a [__] but you get a better
quality of life or you quality life get
hit with reality but you don't have a
childhood which would you rather have
quality of life dude I don't want to die
at 55 for from lung cancer and I didn't
even I didn't even smoke cuz I was
around chemicals and Factory [__] that's
true you got to get a cool job not like
that yeah the thing that sucks is like
it's going to keep doing that until like
like how are you going to find a balance
you know that's why everybody's a [__]
right now a [__] sapiens you know how
you said I think Joe was saying it
yesterday Joe was saying like this is
the safest time ever yep but this is
also the time where we have the most
pusses around [__] and I'm one of I'm
definitely for sure that's why the '90s
kids that grew up in the 9s was like
right before the
internet but the 50s kids look at '90s
kids like y'all [__] and they're
absolutely right I was going to say
they're stupid because they don't know
how to use like you know technology they
don't use a TV remote they're learning
they're learning so you you know why I
think these stories were so Grim is
because one like they didn't hide [__]
from kids in the same way like they
weren't so sensitive right and two I
actually think these stories saved kids
lies cuz you tell them you you scare the
[__] out of them right and now they're
not going to go get lost in the forest
and the pedophile is not going to catch
them and it's easy to remember because
it's a story that's the verion of
stranger I think fear is a good tactic
to teach kids actually stories in
general like stories is the way even
when I talk to clients about like maybe
stories in general yeah yeah like it
just helps them understand okay cool I
remember this it makes it easier for
people to understand but yeah in the
Disney version of even like The Little
Mermaid right um she wins the heart of
the prince gets her voice back
celebrates with a beautiful wedding on a
boat surrounded by her aquatic friends
and family but in the original story uh
her transformation to becoming a human
causes her agonizing pain before her
heart is broken when the prince marries
someone else so the sea which informs
her that if she kills the prince she'll
turn back into a mermaid and live but
she chooses to sacrifice herself
throwing herself to the Sea and becoming
seaf foam oh damn that's a real tragedy
what the mor story is [__] can't fall
for no man dude
[Laughter]
you got to protect yourself yeah that's
a that's a better lesson right Nick yeah
yeah man ain't [__] that's the world the
story men ain't [__] yeah you want to be
seafoam you want to be Ocean Breeze you
want this men ain't sh [__] man are you
guys going to make your kids watch like
Disney movies where they give you like a
false like oh happy ending this is what
life is n dude I'm going to scare the
Trump [__] no dude what mov they need to
know that if you step outside someone's
going to [__] kidnap you and enslave
your ass I might show like jungle for be
like you want me to [__] abandon you
in the forest you grow up with the
animals they like yeah and be like you
see he still wanted to go back to the
Village later I let him choose almost
whatever he wants and he doesn't even go
towards Disney that's tight I'll let
them watch Rumble in the Bronx no right
now it's shaon soccer and Kung Fu Hustle
and he don't even understand it I've
been trying to find ways to find the dub
version I can't even find it it's all
Chinese
what happened he just likes it he just
loves it he loves he watches it over and
over and over yes he loves Rumble in the
Bronx three ninjas just so happen to be
some of my favorite movies Blood
Sport you going to choose whatever you
want and today this is the choice yeah
no but let him choose like I'll show
them what I like and then I let him
choose and then out of the list of he
never goes back to like I thought he was
like Avengers or go back to like
Commando what's Commando one with Arnold
dude come on [__] helicopter and
lands on his 2 feet like a bad does he
know how to choose himself and like dude
these kids that grow up in this
generation taica knew how to do a iPad
even before he spoke it's [__] crazy
it's intuitive yeah it's intuitive this
this gener like I'm like even I'm like
what the [__] the he's just like big
small like he's playing Roblox which is
almost like Minecraft right he's playing
that screenshot he likes this image
screenshot screenshot sends to grandma
sends to Grandma FaceTime goes back and
I can't even move at the speed that he
just did all that [__] at yeah he's a
little genius I'm like what the [__] bro
says a lot about you he probably has
[__] what is it called arthritis
carpal what do you mean what do you mean
says that says time on the video doe
that